what's up chickadees I am back on tour
my solo is stopped for now because the
Impractical Jokers are back on our
national tour huge theater Arena tour
it's going on right this second all
tickets are on sale 40 or 50 cities are
on sale we're adding more just go to
impractical
jokerslive.com for all the cities to
take a look uh coming up off the top
right now we have uh Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Camden New Jersey at the
freedom mortgage Pavilion that's a big
one down Jersey about Philly love to see
you guys two at the Wang in Boston then
we're going to Charleston and Charlotte
and Waterloo New York and then
Washington DC and the big weekend I want
to talk about is Niagara Falls into
Prudential Center in Newark New Jersey
uh then right up to Wallington
Connecticut and coming back down to play
the UBS arena in Long Island those are
all on sale right now plus more and
practicejokerslive.com and Impractical
Jokers season 10 is airing right now on
TruTV and TBS Thursday nights at 10
o'clock folks Joe DeRosa here from the
taste buds podcast I got live
performances and shows and all kinds of
things happening all over the place let
me start with a very special appearance
I'll be making here in New York City on
February 8th at New York City City
Winery my buddy cooge is doing an
evening with cousin friends I'll be
there with couge and some other folks a
little bit of a Roundtable discussion
about food and whatnot lots of laughs
what have you a little bit of a
different show but it's going to be fun
also here in New York City I'm doing my
residency of my new one-man show I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden next one of
those is February 14th the night for
lovers at the crane theater after that
we got one in March on the 22nd again at
the crane theater so if you're in New
York come on by for that and if you're
not in New York I'm hitting the big open
road February 18th Vancouver British
Columbia for jfl's Festival Baton Rouge
on March 9th March 10th Lafayette March
11th New Orleans March 30th Amtrak
Michigan March 31st Grand Rapids
Michigan April 1st Chicago Illinois and
more dates are being added as we speak
all of the dates I just added I
mentioned on the road will be me
performing the I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden Show you can go to
jodarosainfo.com for tickets and info
also don't forget about Joey roses open
seven days a week at 11 30 A.M them
every day sandwiches and booze flowing
and chewing all day long
joeyrosesnyc.com
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic folks welcome to
t-a-s-d-e buds Tasties buddies we're
back we're watching super size episodes
Super Size Me no do not well don't talk
of McDonald's you just did no last
episode we didn't mention it once
episode 115 he's mentioned it in every
single level yeah we didn't mention it
once in the last episode the
continuation the continuation of Indian
food versus Chinese food
yeah part two part two uh we're gonna
we're gonna I mean I'm ready I think we
we I we had a bunch of small talk things
to do but we I think we hit all of them
in the past episodes I think let's just
get into this okay you and I have been
wearing the same episode same outfit for
three episodes in a row now clearly
we're we're not washing or bathing yes
uh and what this is when I bought I
bought two changes of clothes and then I
didn't change I'm carrying out the
Illusions yeah we would like to do it
because then the thumbnail people are
confused not see that that's the Nutty
thing about all these podcasts is like
you got to bring like change of shirts
yeah like after the pandemic I just if I
do multiple podcasts I can't like I I
went on a little run and I realize I had
the same thing on in different locations
same day you know there's going to be an
[__] like hey virgin do you ever
change I know it's tough that shoot but
I I your podcast wardrobe yeah by the
way we forgot to I can't believe we
didn't mention this two full [__]
episodes we didn't mention this people
were like where are they right now
where's the sign where's it this is
we're in our new space that we're gonna
convert into the taste buds Studio
that's right these are the first steps
we're doing here oh you're gonna have
the big size yeah yeah God Almighty
maybe so we got a new a new studio space
yeah so um it's it yeah I I don't know
if we should have probably said that
okay two episodes ago okay it was
Mystique uh I don't know when it's gonna
even be done so it might be like this
for another couple episodes we could at
least get the tile shine down here and
yeah yeah get back I talked to Chris
about that I could get it done in like a
day if I have a key okay yeah yeah oh
was I supposed to take the signage from
Chris's house oh no it's in the studio
okay uh anyway we got to get some
reinforcements on here because those
things are heavy yeah we just need
anchors
right okay no we just need anchors well
it's just no I know that's sheetrock I
know you put anchors the signs are 50
pounds yeah you put anchors in well I
couldn't just put a Necker on my house
Joe you saying that like you [__]
know about it buddy sheetrock buddy I've
been a bachelor my whole life you know
how many times I've moved I'm hanging
everything solo you have no idea the
[__] that I've heard about myself
now if you don't have a stud you use
anchors I know that you can but for me I
never feel comfortable with just the
anchor yeah an entire industry is wrong
and you're right well I I if I sign
drops yeah let me let's call the
hardware industry and tell them Sal's
anxieties have overridden
wall anchors you're going to talk about
it
the 59th minute of a show you're
crushing you have anxiety and it's all
going to turn those were the early days
those were the early days no but I'm
just saying are they're mosaics they're
beautiful pieces of artwork I know but
my point is
you can't you can't depend on a stud
because if there's no stud there then
what are you gonna do not hang it you
gotta hang it you got that's what the
answers
and anchor is the reinforcement that's
what it is this is episode one of
construction buds
Property Brothers
what do you mean by reinforcements what
does that mean no like you find a beam
right or stuff but I'm saying what we
did at my house yeah we put a two by
four on this and drilled it into there
and hung it off the two by four but I'm
saying sometimes you have wall with no
stud and you have to put anchors in
that's the point of an anchor if your
hands are tied and you can't find a stud
fine
that thing is the wise thing to do I'll
be to hang it in a way that's the best
was that your producer's like yeah for
nothing I'm gonna all right I don't even
know what an answer is let's talk about
how Joe didn't make it to Jesus Christ
it falls though huh how you weren't
invited to Stefano's Christmas Stefano
that pig didn't invite me to his
daughter's Christian he invited
everybody we know and I told him today I
go I'm a little hurt all of no pressure
was there yeah yeah and he goes I go I'm
a little hurt he goes I only invited
Comics I had kids I didn't think you'd
want to come to it on Staten Island I
mean I I I yeah well that's because I
live in Staten Island you know yes yes
yeah and he goes he goes uh he goes I
didn't honestly I didn't think you'd
want to come all the way to Staten
Island for this if you lived closer I
would have invited you and I wrote back
I can't argue with a word you're saying
I never would have come
quite frankly I was relieved you didn't
invite me but but then I wrote to him I
go I'm such a [__] I had fomo about a
baptism
that's funny
dude I can't that's funny if I don't get
asked I just I I'm so sensitive dude I
gotta get over it I gotta get over it
I'm so sensitive I'm so sensitive it's
terrible you got your insult right there
I think
we're all I was at a I talked to Dr Drew
about it I did the doctor Drew podcast
and I talked about it what did he tell
you did he help you he just was like Joe
like what's going on he's like why the
[__] you're being so sensitive you're
like oh easy yeah but the thing is
comedians all of us have all of us from
I talk to all the friends it's all
insecurity there's all insecurity and
this and that and then I think when we
get the mic we kind of put that aside
because it's the time to put that aside
and afterwards we're like hey do you
like me yeah yeah we're all [__] it's
brutal dude I'm also I'm going through a
thing though being 45 and still a
bachelor yeah uh my feet why do you go
on The Bachelor huh why don't you go on
the patch they should make an
entertainment they should do a pig
version of The Bachelor with me in
Northeast Philly
she's a [__] dude we're all in a row
home we're on a row home in Northeast
Philly
and it's all waitresses
we gotta do that dude oh my God
you you you should do I would love to
see you on the regular Bachelor though
and and I think could we could I get
that I might be able we might be able to
put you in a position to at least have a
chance all right if you were on The
Bachelor I swear to God it would be
appointment television
you would not know DVR no [__] I'll
watch it tomorrow never seen a single
episode of The Bachelor in my entire
life not a single episode not one but
I've seen clippets of this like the rose
and stuff like that right and uh I I
don't know how many people are on there
like how many Bachelors I my guess is
like 20 I don't know right
no no The Bachelor is the it's just one
guy and then it's all women oh so maybe
no but I want you on The Bachelorette
then oh I'd have to compete with the
other guys
no no no no you're right you're on the
back no yeah
what I was gonna say was if he was on
The Bachelorette 20 guys right now right
now I'll take bets odds are that he gets
illuminated as the first guy yeah of
course
immediately he'd be ripping on
everything I didn't want your [__]
Rose yeah he's stupid you're stupid no
it's got to be him deciding over trashy
Philly waitresses yeah that's what it
has to be yeah and then you have to
bring him in the room and sit down in
front of the camera and let him describe
why the roads of love oh my yeah Rose of
love oh my God
I made I made you a [__] Hoagie and
you did this to me [__] you dude you
threw water in my face
threw a vessel
next season of Gillian keeves you have
to dude it's I swear to God I think
we've got to do this for real dude
I love I see it's 12 girls competed I
called the the golden derozies dozen we
gotta do this we gotta do this we gotta
we gotta do this we gotta do this how
many weeks can we shoot it uh we shoot
over the course of one week like can we
condense it to a point yeah just go
where there's a row of bars or something
no no but hold on there's got to be
authenticity in it because other than
that it's just stick I know so I would I
got I need the I need you to really be
looking for love with these women though
otherwise why am I you got nowhere to go
let's go
let's go oh dude this this is wild
I want to see this show I swear that's
what I'm saying if we could shoot it in
like six days like four episodes in six
days like dude you buzzed DeRosa buzzed
in a bar is like a [__] lion and it
just that is where he [__] belongs to
that is his domain every day you know
how they do the confessionals every day
he goes into the variety box and he just
talks to America like I don't know like
maybe we do like a text to voting no
here's my face you're gonna have a
million questions
said she's on a pill I don't know no Sal
he was my favorite thing my favorite
thing about here's DeRosa and I know you
heard this a million times DeRosa in a
bar with a couple of drinks in a good
mood and women there and you go hey dude
I gotta go you leaving
why the [__] you leave dude [__] you you
have one dude stay
dude it's it truly is it truly is my
happy place it scares me how much I'm
happy there it scares me how happy I am
at a dive bar with a perfect Buzz I see
it that's the set oh my God that's like
the main set you're I've never I've
actually the pure joy I was leaving New
York it was the it was the bar next to
the old stand is it Patty McGuire one of
the all-time great yeah like around the
holidays it's like New York City like if
they were doing a movie at a bar in New
York City yeah that's what it is uh and
Joe's sitting there and he had he just
had that smell like birds where are you
going you wanna have a drink he looked
so [__] content and happy and there
was just New York City Bar it's just
gonna happen don't don't destroyed my
personal life here
do they live in a house together for the
bachelorettes I believe they do they
live in like a house that's what it is
right it's a [__] neighborhood bar
downstairs where they do like the rose
ceremony and they live in the building
they live in the building above the bar
but we have got to be at least six
floors it's got to be at least six
floors just so you get a knock up you
guys all live in the house above the bar
oh it's so funny dude we gotta get some
McDonald's in this though huh we need a
McDonald's plug in this no that's that's
where the date that's where the dinner
instead of a rose oh god dude yeah
instead of instead of instead of a rose
she chose like it shows like uh you know
[__] Sally please step up
but you get a glass of whiskey here's
here's how you do this it's a glass of
whiskey ceremony you don't tell them
any of the stuff that we're talking
about right now right
and all the activities are things that I
like to do
so that sprung on them so like it's like
on The Bachelor they have to like go on
dates and stuff and it's always dates to
like see if they bond but all the dates
will be my things we're gonna be like we
go to McDonald's chill we play we're
gonna go play Playstation together
Jill tonight's your night your date with
Joe uh tonight you guys have a fun night
planned you're gonna watch cartoons and
listen to cassette tapes yeah exactly
exactly make a taco kit yeah do you
bring the girl in to talk about it too
the girl goes into the room alone to
talk yeah yeah
yeah because you're gonna have people
pissed off dude he [__] played Xbox
one I can't go out there were KFC boxes
all over the house
to date KFC today McDonald's is a date
McDonald's is a date yeah uh uh retro
video games is a date so it's 12 women
12 episodes 12 dates no two two women
Tour episode no they're all competing I
can shave it down they all compete at
the same time are they like trying to
talk to you and then someone came in two
dates an episode you know
streamline this thing yeah but they all
should be competing for you at the same
time no they are and then whoever like
says tonight so that's the right point
if you do if you do yeah you usually
take them out to like an island
somewhere or a mansion it's all it is is
we're going to an island
could be a date
that would be a date
yeah what's Ferry Rock
a ferry ride oh a fairy ride okay by the
way that is a good date
it's a fun little affordable free date
you know you get you can get an ice cold
beer on there it's free you drive across
the harbor you look at the Statue
uh no the ride's free ferries free you
can buy a tall boy for 350. it's ice
cold
that's that's I love it we got to do we
gotta go ahead go ahead nothing I was
just gonna say we should do the battle
we're gonna get we're gonna do another
episode we don't get to the [__]
battle sorry I keep saying f
it's a lot of bleeps on pimps Park uh I
love this idea Rose of love
that's what you said right yeah the rose
of Love yeah all right
I think we do it man I think we do it I
think we've we just we backed up but are
you I'd be looking for are you do you
really want to get like 12 like bowling
alley waitresses nothing against bowling
alley waitresses
let's make a distinction the their their
job has nothing to do with what they're
like no you're saying that because in
your head you have a vision of a certain
type of person and you're making that
person I was I was I no no no I I I'm
not saying it to uh in any way disparage
uh the service industry I'm saying it
because of the places I like to hang out
in yeah uh it should be people that come
from that life it should be people that
work like in bars but is that where you
would want to find like love what do I
know I haven't found I don't know you
know what I mean what about Hooters yeah
I guess he loved that Hooters waitress
last episode she was great she was great
oh yes a Hooters waitress would be a
nice episode
I remember when Hooters opened up near
the first food is open on Staten Island
and we were in high school and and we
used to go there all the time it was
like our strip club like because they
all stick they'll come over and sit at
the table and talk to you and you think
they like you did you know there's
everyone's like oh dude I think the
originals in Tampa this is what it's
about they come over and sit and like
talk to you I mean did you know that
Florida I don't know if these are
everywhere but I saw them in Florida
there's like a condensed Hooters now
what do you mean
there's like a Hooters that's like it's
it's it's a derivative of Hooters oh
it's a smaller yes yeah and it's just
like it's basically like a takeout only
it's called Hooter it's called like
Hoots or something and there's no
there's the girls don't have their boobs
out or anything and and me and Patty
Walsh were down there doing uh doing
we'll see you in hell live and we saw it
and we were like what the [__] is this
yeah and the guy uh who was who who owns
the uh really nice kid that owns the
club that we were doing down there
Coastal creative uh he was telling us he
goes oh it's like Hooters except it's
like just it's just the food they don't
have the waitresses and Pat was like
to this day to this day they were like
you know we should make a let's do a
restaurant what should we serve [__]
fries Wings How You Gonna Stand Out
titties we'll call it we'll call it
titties we'll only hire girls they'll
titties will be out we'll put them in
short shorts we'll just call it titties
and they'll come and you can get fries
and look at titties and like they can't
call it titties dude so fine we'll just
call it Hooters it means titties and
we'll just put an owlette I mean you
literally are going to a restaurant
called titties it was of the it was of a
certain error there was a picture now no
I know but I'm saying there was a period
in this country in the 90s that was very
popular this like it's porn but it's not
porn
Hooters was the strip club equivalent
like it's a strip club but it's not a
strip club Maxim magazine stuff yes that
was a big thing back then where it was
like oh it's salacious but like you
bring the kids along still which was
weird like the fact that Hooters would
like sponsor like little league teams
and stuff I found that very very weird
right well that's the great plan they
tried to like make it just like they
tried to know it's normal now it's not
like Hooters like a family restaurant
now yeah but do they still have they
still have the whole elf like yeah I
don't know yeah yeah it's just like you
wouldn't if you saw a chick right now
you'd see a chick work at a bank as a
bank teller in that outfit now you
wouldn't even bat an eye at it this
country's so deep in the [__] sewer
at this point yeah yeah
like it's it's nothing now like but back
then it was like it's funny that it's
like not direct like a strip club is
like this girl is owning it and she's
gonna make money off of it of what she
has and what God she's empowered right
but at Hooters they're like
they're gonna be staring at you but like
don't don't like you can't take a tit
out you can't you know just yes because
they're in such a rough just put on
something tight they're gonna be staring
it's wild but just bring over fries and
we just We're not gonna talk about that
part and like you know what I mean so
you you need to show your things but you
can't let them really they're gonna look
at you like what is this think about
this think about this and this is wild
this is wild the episode should have
been Hooters Hooters yay or nay
I have so much to say about Hooters the
uh
Paul it's a four-parter
you got time yeah all right Indian
Hooters versus Chinese no but who that's
the thing like Hooters now
it's such an interesting Paradox now
because in one way it represents the
empowerment and like go out there and
you work your thing and I'm always
confused about that whole thing and then
on the other then it also represents
everything that that people would rail
against objectifying yeah where it's
like it's like you're going to determine
if a woman deserves this job based on
her breast size you know what I mean or
whatever yeah like it's such a weird
what about if they made like a Hooters
but like a new version of like to make
everybody included body's beautiful and
it was just a bunch of lizos [__]
working like just just [__] right did
you see South Park South Park uh like uh
Lampoons it and they go it's young it's
the kids working there they call it
raisins oh I swear to God like welcome
to raisins there's they they parody
Hooters on South Park and the
restaurant's called raisins and it's all
kids with no boobs well I mean it is
kids that worked even though that that
Universe the kids are like adults the
only way you can do it do an animation
of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
a genius idea that's up for grabs is
Hooters but all the waitresses have only
fans
that's a good idea so you get a bunch of
features that's a good idea pimp I
actually would if I were you and I'm not
kidding I would cut that out of the Pod
I would I would keep that close to the
best that's right I'm actually a pimp
though I can't do it yeah no that's a
good idea
if I'm dead serious I would I would keep
that idea closely don't make me a few
bucks dude yeah maybe Yeah well yeah all
right Let's do let's do the battle all
right version you ready this is how the
uh
it's time to get salty Chan work okay we
look eye to eye you say it three times
sorry we can start to be telling
yourself I launched it it's all right at
you and we do it at the same time I
don't know one of us goes you can go
first or second it's up to you but one
of us launches right okay you don't go
heavy in just 10 seconds 20 seconds
right and then
yeah and then we do it again you launch
one back at me would you like to go
first or second the idea here is that
it's going to set the tone for a
contentious battle Yeah uh I'll go I'll
go second check it I'll go check smart
because you can get to see what he
launches at you all right ready
here we go it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
how are your clothes tight and loose at
the same time
I don't understand what's going on
it's three minutes
late are you ready uh hold on okay yeah
give me a second here I have you know
yeah me and Joe have you know really
gotten along the left yeah
um did you have that in the pocket
I thought of it when he walked in today
and I was like I got to do a salty with
version so I can get this out
but it's been in my head for about two
hours because they're not too yeah it's
so funny you told the line it's funny it
is
um all right here we go I don't know you
gotta just first thing comes in your
head that's the whole thing okay I know
I just contradicted that but like don't
overthink it okay we're sitting at the
table we're [__] on each other ready
okay it's time to get salty it's time to
get salty it's tiny and salty you are an
angry prick
when are you gonna let go of it okay
things are okay never was that a good
one
because you're making your identity and
it doesn't have to be it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy and you take a
couple of steps back and say this
doesn't have to be my identity then you
won't always have to check your own box
to make sure you're angry you you feed
it into yourself
he's like well just say something quick
yup yo versus I got you on I got your
back imagine back on this one imagine if
DeRosa does the show does the Roses show
right get some [__] waitress in
Philly and then he just is never angry
like he's just completely back yeah he's
just like dude I'm just I needed this I
need it you this might be it for you it
might be it might be but I I I I I don't
know what's so funny is you have a yin
yang you have a totally cheery pleasant
good mood size
me and him had an Italian me and him had
an Italian dinner one night and we're
sitting there we're drinking wine we
went he got tickets to see the uh with a
sneak peek of the Irishman and I was
like this is a happy [__] this is a
[__] happy guy and then he's on stage
in one joke just gets still good but not
enough you [__] people suck
I uh I I I I I am I don't but you you
what the term is but you you it's not
angry you don't Larry David I'm it's
Larry David I'm disgruntled I'm annoyed
I'm irritated you know what I mean yeah
but he's like that in real life I can't
I can't let things go like something
gets in me and I'm like I'm the same I'm
the same way I just don't you express
I'll overthink it I'll get anxiety of it
but I probably won't get angry outwardly
angry I would go the other way with you
I'd say stop putting a face on for
everybody we know there's rage we know
there's rages no there's anxiety and
doubt I question everything 10 times
over it's a it's a it's a it's his
mental prison listen but I don't get
angry I know but I'm saying I think you
have anger in you and you don't let it
out
Sal have you been in your house and you
just [__] you just are having a
something is you're just having a it's
either something with a a business
relationship or something with with your
career and you just thrush and like do
you ever have those moments
I have why I don't throw anything I'm
sure I've I don't know in my life have I
like screamed into a pillow or something
maybe Well that took a different
direction
throw anything you know I'll get so so
mad that I'll get like a literally a
[__] tension headache and I might
have to take a knee oh so you just
that's internalized this is the
difference you're a go for a walk guy
yeah I should go for him I I'm I should
go for a while you're right yelling the
pillow but I should have went for a lap
I don't know what I do I just
internalize it and then I just walk
around with a heavy this is five I know
the difference between yeah this is this
is the difference between you and me I'm
not saying one's right or one's wrong
I'm saying this is the difference
between you and me with the anger we're
both Anakin Skywalker in the prequels
okay your Anakin earlier on
where you're just like
like darts Darth uh Darth taranis even
says to him he goes uh he goes you have
much anger in you but you don't use it
you know and Anakin he's just like it's
always just like and he's gonna I'm
gonna go over here I'm Anakin in in
Revenge of Sith when when tyrannis does
that to him and there's that moment
where he goes
yeah
we're just two versions of that guy I'm
like you know what [__] it I'm going
into the suit I don't give a [__]
you have to back off from that like
nowadays I will be like
breathe I will [__] breathe I will I
will I will not try to make any
emotional uh response or emotional
judgment I want to walk away from it I
want to take any I want to do because
I'm going to give myself a [__]
stroke yeah yeah uh I I try to now be
like
have like this thing that you go
You Gotta Laugh yeah even though I'm
like you gotta laugh and I'm like I
wanna there's people there's a few
people out there I swear to God that I
yeah I I want to put a headache and here
and here's the thing and I'm glad you
just hold on I think about it and I
think about can I can I can I actually
get it away
I'm glad you said that I'm glad you said
that because I gotta get this out
because here's what it is here's what it
is good you're Michael Corleone coming
from the war yeah and you're introducing
Kay to the family and you're sitting
here that's Luca Brasi and you're but
you're very much like this but when
you're sitting down and everybody's
talking about the hit that just happened
on the father you sit there quietly I
think the the Michael that comes out
where he's like you gotta you gotta kill
him you gotta do that I think that that
is what I think that you're at that
point we're all like dude like one of my
arrows in my head what what point am I
at then am I just Sunny yeah you're
sunny
but here's the this is interesting
you're this you're this
you bite the Fist and you go right to
the thing I definitely like I can't tell
you how many times in my house
throughout one week where I'll go like
this I go
like that because it's just something
you know what I mean but like by the way
he just called that up and felt that
anger even though he was just showing
yeah I have direct access to it but but
I I I will say this
anger is like a 24-hour Planet Fitness
I will say this though and this is
really telling and I don't say this to
justify any of my own stuff it's just
very interesting about the difference
between you and me what you just said is
so different for me you just said there
are people out there I'd like to put a
hit out on if I could I am I will show
it and within minutes be like dude I'm
sorry yeah oh I don't mean anyone in my
life like that I just mean there as like
but I mean three or four people that
have wronged me or people I know in such
a way and they're pieces of [__] and
they hurt you and I was like I don't
care this guy no no no no I do not care
right I understand no no that I
understand what I'm saying though is is
I always express it but I carry very
very few grudges I I express it I get it
out and then I'm like and then look five
minutes later there might be something
else yeah but you'd be surprised you'd
be you would be surprised that if you
could get in my head at night at bedtime
I'm not saying there's not anxieties and
things like that you would be shocked at
how few how few grudging are in there
and things like that you know what I
mean it's just something in the moment I
will get so hung up on it that sounds
like the horrific horror movie to be in
your head at bedtime sounds like I'd
rather go to the [__] Last House on
the Left like that this I don't know
that's an echo Chamber Of Madness in
there what you think you think you're
inside your head's gonna be a walk in
the pool no but I'm already in it I know
what I'm dealing with I know what I'm
dealing with
side there could be a whole new level
but I'm saying I'm saying if you if you
you'd be surprised the other way you're
saying that you let it go and you kind
of put that aside at night you're done
I'm saying like last night right I saw a
clip on Instagram that a friend of all
of ours put up grip the clip made me so
sick to my stomach
that I called can't you can't do that
too much longer what you can't make
something like that and move you that
much in that direction it's not healthy
right I know because I I feel I I do
that and then I push it down but I'm
telling you but I'm telling you
something okay I called four different
people to talk [__] about it I finally
got Bobby Kelly on the phone
what can you do yeah I started what are
you gonna do Bobby's response was yeah
we're [__] done dude so grab whatever
you can because the ship's going down
comedy stinks now right and I was like
yeah and I go I go you know what I
wanted this to be bigger than it was and
he goes yeah dude I'm sorry I didn't
like talk to you when you were really
fired up it probably would have been fun
I go yeah yeah oh well all right forget
it and then I wasn't mad about it
anymore yeah uh that's the kind of [__]
I get wound up about you know what I
mean like or if somebody slights me yeah
well you promised me when this podcast
is over you'll tell me rocket money
formerly known as true bill is here to
help you with what those unwanted
subscriptions that you forgot about
folks we all do it you sign up for
things whether it's a streaming service
or some kind of recurring uh
Subscription Service whatever it is and
you forget you forget you forget and in
your head when you know you're gonna
forget you say well what's 5.99 I'm
looking at you Apple games what's 9.99
well it adds up folks and that's why
rocket money was created that's what
they're there to do to or that's why how
they're here to help is to help you
locate these things find these
subscriptions let you know what you're
spending every month and let you cancel
the things you don't want to do anymore
how great is that to you could look at
all your subscriptions at a glance and
cancel them at the same place with a
touch of a button yeah you press cancel
that's it yeah you're done all with in
the app stop throwing your money away
cancel those unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses uh how the easy way
quite frankly go to rocketmoney.com
tastebuds that's rocketmoney.com
tastebuds
rocketmoney.com taste buds this show is
sponsored by better better help better
help is so great uh I use better help
that is how I do therapy uh and why do I
do therapy through better help and why
do I suggest that you might want to try
this yourself I will tell you why
because betterhelp is an app or service
that has taken all of the bureaucratic
nonsense out of getting you the mental
uh therapy coaching whatever you want to
call it whatever term you want to put on
it that you need okay uh life is tough
there is no handbook there is no how-to
guide all you can do is just go in your
instincts your intuition and you're
probably at times going to need some
assistance some of us might need a
little more than other people there's no
shame in that I am one of the people
that needs a little bit more and I know
that I have gotten overwhelmed by life's
challenges and even more overwhelmed by
trying to fix those challenges when I'm
faced with a very complicated system on
how to do so better help links you
instantly with trained professionals uh
that that are are vetted and there to
get the job done why because they're
qualified to get the job done you can
switch between if you're not vibing with
your therapist your licensed therapist
licensed therapist you can switch at any
point whenever you want there's no
weirdness or more affordable than
in-person therapy it's easier than in
person therapy you don't even have to
show your face if you don't want to a
lot of times people don't know that they
could use help you could do they don't
think they need help I I use it I do it
through the app you can do video calls
you can do phone calls you can do chats
it's incredible thinking of starting it
this is a great option to start if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com taste buds today to get
10 off your first month okay that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com taste buds yeah I do have a
question what do you do more times a
year scream or cry oh God
I cried twice not me I don't I don't cry
it's weird oh but not that event cry for
whatever reason I like tearing yeah I'm
an emotional fellow
I am I'll cry I I told you I cried a Pep
Boys commercial I'd cry looking at my my
life thinking of my grandparents I'll
cry thinking of my life I cry laugh and
yell evenly throughout every day wow
that's like a Jimmy Valvano that's what
he said if you do that you're living I
don't know I know I saw that question
that dude
I've even killed or the definition of
incentive I don't either
I don't know you know I don't know I
don't know I don't know but I I I I
they're pretty evenly now now when I say
evenly every day that's an exaggeration
but I say evenly threat every week
yesterday I laughed out loud I said last
two episodes ago I had watched I just
Marathon King of Queens
and like when I'm like having it
yesterday was sort of a dreary Sunday it
was kind of look like you know I knew we
had to record today I knew I had to get
up early to do this me like I was like
having Sunday scaries I was kind of
stressed
and I put it on to cheer me up and I
laughed out loud so many times
throughout the day yesterday
and then I have other days where it's
like oh like around Christmas like
especially this year certain things were
just shut me off I was just [__]
crying songs come on I'm like yeah done
oh yeah it's brutal dude it's brutal
dude what gets me emotional not Brutal
bad but it's just you know it gives me
emotional now is like seeing people even
younger or all just getting old like
seeing people getting older and seeing
family members oh like dude that's
brutal I saw his therapy for me I saw a
picture of somebody that and like just
seeing like the wrinkles and stuff and
I'm just going like well dude it's just
it's like in the movies when you see
them put the makeup on as the person
progresses and like you're living that
and that's [__] up man you're like
dude dude this middle middle area here
this transitional area that we're in
right now it sucks it's crazy that's
right we're looking forward and backward
and you're like oh my God you're like
caught in the middle there that's what I
was gonna say earlier we got way
sidetracked it might have even been the
last episode at this point now that I'm
45 and still a bachelor if it's [__]
with me bad like I get really that's
something at night it's not anger dude
it's fear I I'm like what if I die alone
like what if what if my brother went
through that and my older brother my
older brother said my older my other
brother went through that and he settled
down around for 47 48 and it was just
like he was like in the same thing but
then he also has to be the right like
person I gotta tell you dude I feel like
I feel like
just like with I feel like for me
monogamy in a committed relationship is
gonna be like success yeah if it came
earlier I would have been like I would
have [__] it up I wouldn't have known
how to handle it yeah he's not a guy I
remember hearing Ray Romano saying like
thank God it happened his we sort of his
career he was always a family guy but he
was like I he goes if thank God it
happened when it did I would have I was
ready to handle it yeah now I have no
idea if I'll ever see those Heights of
success but I can say as a 45 year old
man and feeling like over these last few
years really like it's coming together
you know with with a bunch of different
things I'm like thank God this is
happening now man because I would have
[__] this up yeah I had bad habits you
know like I said about stand up in the
last episode where it's like I used to
go to this place where if I wasn't happy
with the show I'd be like I'll burn this
[__] show to the ground right now
like knowing now don't do that right
don't do that you can't do that you know
what I mean and whatever like I feel
that way about monogamy and commitment
I'm like I would because I didn't
understand it I had a really long talk
with Giannis about this recently and he
said some stuff that came to him from
your stepfather yeah yep he passed some
gems he dropped some jewels on me from
your stepfather that where I was like
holy [__] did Giannis just change the
way I think yeah like or did Paul's
Snapchat
it was wild and I was like I wouldn't
have understood that two years ago even
yeah you know I I uh yeah I love it one
of one of the saddest things I saw and I
got a partner that's got you back you
make sure you put each other first you
know what I mean and it's just a mutual
appreciation and like I I you know I I
once I really like settle down to a
serious relationship I was like this is
the best thing I've ever done
you know what's funny too I just I
realized last night for the first time I
was like because I get it I get all in
this sometimes this personal space and
also and I'm like dude
you're not gonna live in this apartment
with your partner you know what I mean
right you're living in a bachelor's
apartment I keep picturing it in my
apartment that I'm in right now right of
course I could oh my God hell on her and
I'm like oh dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in the fourth or fifth month of my 45th
year I finally realized we would live in
a bigger place together
are we a Time
like we missed the battle again no we
didn't miss it we gotta do it
um and you and you got salty and then
you started doing Heart to Heart
brought up a thing and it it set us up
but it's such a good convo but the last
the last thing I'll say is I saw I was
in Atlanta with an older comedian you
know I don't want to mention the name
now but he's older no he's kind of a
legend and he was sitting at the
Georgetown bar and he's just looking at
this red wine
and I remember him just going to it and
I remember being like dude that's I
[__] did it right because he just
goes yeah man I almost married her I
almost like he was like I almost got
married once and he's like in his I
think 60s at the time I think he might
be 70 now guy's a [__] Legend and I
just saw that loneliness and I saw the
wine and I'm like then you see him going
to his hotel room and I was like [__]
that [__] dude it was it was it was it
was Heavy to see yeah but then you see
the opposite right yeah of the guy that
does it right and maybe does it right a
little bit later on or whatever you know
it's good good for that is uh George
Clooney George Clooney
I mean with Comics a guy that put it
like real in perspective for me was uh
was Bobby Slayton and I think he was
actually married once yeah she's like I
think yeah I think he's got a daughter
right but
the last time I saw him we were doing I
oh I opened for him a few years back
pre-pandemic in Vegas yeah we both lived
in L.A and he was like telling me about
he lives I don't know if they're still
together but he lives with his
girlfriend and and he was imagine that's
the comic he was talking about
wait it was it was yeah
I remember he said to me he just yeah he
goes we were the second night of shows
it was two nights of shows and the
second show night of shows in Vegas and
I was you know I was like ready to tear
[__] up it was Vegas
and I was like what are you doing you
want to hang out he's like yeah
I used to man he was uh I gotta drive
home tonight man he's like my
girlfriend's waiting for me she made a
salmon salad we're gonna open a bottle
of wine and get in the hot tub I was
like yeah I was like dude that actually
sounds pretty great
uh you know but uh but you know like he
but I remember that was a moment where
he just just what he described
it wasn't so much the elements of it it
wasn't so much day of a hot tub and they
have wine and they have this food and
they're it wasn't so much that it was
way more just like the idea of somebody
is waiting for what he has there yeah
and they're and they're taking care of
me tonight because tonight tonight when
I need it and you could tell that he
would do the same for her and it was
just like I was like uh like I get it
like that I kind of get that you know
yeah I mean I I I you know you got to be
really compatible with that person's
like one of your best friends like
that's where it is no they say something
like hey when you come home tonight
everybody's gonna be sleeping but
there's something in the fridge and this
and that and like you're it's just like
this nice it's a nice thing I love being
with my the my lady I love being with
her I I told her not that long ago I was
like we were in the kitchen she was
cooking or something like that right and
I and she was busy you know and I as she
was busy I said you know what babe I was
like
if I could choose to experience nearly
everything with you
I don't even think that's a bad idea I
probably would do it because I just feel
like when we're together I enjoy
everything so much more so I would
choose to just be with you if I could
constantly right and she said
put these two plates on the coffee table
but it's hard for comments
that's [__] that's [__] great
bring this to the coffee table are you
kidding me right now
um let me crack that point yeah no the
the last thing I'll say is We're Young
and like the immaturity thing that we
have it's not even like a it's that the
life we live and go get some do shows
get some drinks and do that and then you
come home and somebody's kind of telling
you what to do I fought it for a while
and my wife is a [__] you know my wife
my wife is very much my wife is a
[__] my wife 10 out of 10. dude if my
my wife would win Wars as a [__]
General dude she just she's [__]
lined up it's ready it's organized and I
wasn't but sometimes it would cause a
lot of fights because I'd be like let me
[__] let's just I'm a little more
like let me [__] go at my Pace he's
like no you know this but then when I
realized I was like a like a rescue dog
that needed to be domesticated in a way
I still wanted my own [__] but I I
realized like no this is like real adult
[__] yeah and once I got that it was
[__] fantastic you're uh you both of
your significant others are people that
that you know for me it's been getting a
step closer the older I get right and
seeing relationships where I understand
oh okay I never saw that kind hopefully
more than likely you're going to meet
someone who knows themselves more than
they did before and that's a good thing
exactly and like so that's the that's
but but I'm not blowing smoke here both
of your significant others
uh and and a little more yours because
obviously we're collecting very close at
this point
um you know they're they're people that
made me understand it a little more when
I saw your relationships you know what I
mean and one of them
was at some we were we were all
somewhere together
uh and somebody so I'd already I was
getting to know
sales person at the time and I was like
wow
I already knew she was cool but man
she's really great you know and like
whatever and then and then I had was
talking to you and your wife was there
and I remember this I know what you're
gonna say I'm not gonna say any names
but somebody made a like a little like
kind of sideways joke at your wife yeah
and your wife
like it was the kind of thing where a
guy like you traditionally you know what
I mean by that like a guy like you would
have gone
hey brother don't you know what I mean
and your wife before you even a chance
was like don't [__] talk to me like
that to the guy that's wild man and yeah
it was it was that it was that something
that you know well but yes uh Stacy
somebody said something we were talking
and Stacy just goes and Stacy and dude I
was it was so me and Joe it was such a
showstopper that Joe and I stopped and I
just go I think I go like this I go I go
does anybody need a drink dude yeah she
goes like this she goes he goes yeah but
you're not gonna make this he just said
something along the lines if you're not
gonna make decision or what do you know
and she goes whoa she goes don't you
ever talk to me like that again and dude
this dude got white and Joe just kind of
and I just go I'm gonna go get a drink
and and then afterwards like he was
apologizing to her and stuff but uh well
I'll tell you after yeah but yeah but
like my lady yeah they're they're close
but yeah they're very like similar in a
way of like getting [__] done but yeah
that was a moment excuse me excuse me
that was a moment that I remembered
for two reasons number one like I said
it was it was something where I was kind
of getting to know Sal's person better
so that was already in my head and on
the table and then seeing your your wife
do that and I was like
that's I was like that's who you want to
marry man that's that's who you that's a
wife that's right well the fact that you
know that is great yeah yeah you know
they both sharing each other's interests
so like that's really great and here's
the most here's for me and I'll just
turn into a doctor jewelry of itself we
got to get to Curry versus Duck Sauce
soon but I would say the Fan's gonna be
pissed if we do two reps with no battle
well we told them was gonna be a battle
this time but we still got battle time
we still got battle time I'll tell you
what oh no yes dude I'm not gonna lie
I've done a lot of podcasts lately this
second one we did is is pretty [__]
dope yeah I mean it's a banger dude I'm
not mad dude look we pushed the battle
three amps before on my birthday we went
two full UPS through this but we can't
we who's gonna do it he's gonna leave we
gotta I gotta I gotta do the other
podcast no I'm saying I'm not saying we
do it right now say we're just gonna
have to come back I don't know well
we're not gonna do it no we should do it
we should do it we should do it just go
go we'll do it to do an hour ten you get
20 minutes of battle and that's plenty
okay we can even do that Chinese food it
might even be 15 minutes yeah yeah no
because I mean it's you know 10 minutes
10 minutes what I was gonna say yeah I
don't wanna uh I just feel bad I want to
keep talking about this stuff all right
but we gotta go I think I was gonna say
was the most important thing is to know
how to disagree and know how to argue
right yes right you could have a long
time interviews yeah you can go at a
little bit it could be a little static
but you have to know when to let go you
have to know when to say you're wrong
and you have to know if you if you agree
to disagree it's the it's the way you
repair from from disagreement and
friction that I think is the most
important thing and to know that this is
this is a little bit a trite but to know
that like
it's it's always evolving the
relationship is never going to be what
it was in the beginning later and later
you just got to accept that the
relationship is the dynamic the Rapport
and everything that you experience
you're going to go through different
stages I'll drop the gem that that
verses stepdad dropped on Giannis yeah
that Giannis then dropped on me years
later
I believe this was it he said love love
is action not feeling yeah and and uh
and he goes and Giannis goes that's when
it that just changed the way I thought
about everything and I go oh yeah and it
blew my mind it's a crazy because
as I get older that's what excites me
about when I meet somebody that I might
want to hang out with I'm like the first
thing I start thinking about now versus
what used to excite me
is is can I learn anything from this
person you know what I mean like can
this person teach me something or show
or show me some and I don't mean like
because they're
a scholar genius I just mean can they
teach me something are they well-rounded
and fulfilled enough as a human being
that they could teach me something and
uh instead of what I used to get excited
about which would be like
oh my God her favorite movie is my
favorite movie and that means it's got
to be that where you know what I mean
like yeah that that's a nice perk if
that's the case but
you know but but you know and obviously
one of similar tastes and I would think
yeah uh you know but but
that when he said that I was like that's
wild because that's really been on my
mind lately like can this person teach
me something and that to me is somebody
that loves you that's what that love is
action you know he said another one to
me where he said Love sometimes when
you're a hundred percent right and
they're wrong you still apologize to
them and I was like no
I said I'm not doing it I said that's
where I draw the [__] line if I'm 100
right I'm not apologizing to anybody
folks I'm a Nostalgia junkie I've
probably made that very evident here on
the show and why is that because
childhood was a simpler time and one of
the things that made that time so simple
so beautiful was what cereal babe cereal
a thing that Fades out of adult life as
you get older sadly unless it's a
non-fun cereal uh and that's where magic
spoon changed everything you want to
talk about some game changers magic
spoon is replicated your favorite
childhood cereals to taste good but with
servings that have zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and four to
five net grams of carbs really really
great stuff it's a keto friendly
gluten-free grain free and soy free way
to relive those moments watching your
favorite cartoons that's so funny they
say that because Saturday morning
cartoons and a bowl of cereal was it
plus it's only 140 calories a serving
it's like there's magic in every
Spoonful with with over eight unique
flavors which they added because they I
don't know if they had eight in the past
you won't get bored of feeling good with
magic spoon uh I enjoy all of the no
well I'm you know I don't mean to say I
enjoy all of them but they all are very
good uh but if I had to pick my
preferences I like the fruit uh flavor
very very much and I really really like
the blueberry muffin those just do it
for me but if you like a different kind
of sweet in your cereal they've got
Maple waffle they've got Honey Nut
they've got cookies and cream uh
cinnamon roll peanut butter I took the
cocoa and the peanut butter I'm mixing
I'm crazy like I've mixed my blueberry
muffin with my fruity and I enjoy it so
we love it so head to magicspoon.com
tastebuds to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try the magic for yourself
and be sure to use our promo code taste
buds at checkout to save five bucks off
your order and Magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions s
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
Taste Buds and use the code taste buds
to save five dollars off thanks magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
that's funny yeah that was that was one
but he's like he's on there like like
like he like myself he's like a Jedi on
that like he's just like no you know you
apologize even when you're wrong and I
I'm not I can't I don't know what I
can't if I'm right and you're dead the
rights I gotta tell you you have to be
self-aware and always you you always
have to be contributed there's your clip
right that's something I did you always
have to be contributing to the
relationship you can't put it in neutral
or cruise control and then go about your
business and be like we're married and
like and that or whatever it is we're in
a relationship we're married you can't
you have to you have to be like think of
them and be like what can I do for them
that they're not expecting how can I
make them feel better good or better
what's something I could do like you
have to be outwardly caring there's
there's I will say this very sincerely
on camera
two people in my life in recent years
that are not women that I feel these
love things about are you
and uh Paul Italia I opened the bar with
Paul and then you and I started this
podcast together and and and pimp you're
a huge part of that too to please
[Laughter]
how do you have that but my point is is
like my point is is like the there's
there's so much time spent in dealing
with work stuff at that point there's
immense levels of Joy but then there are
also immense levels of frustration you
and I have had blow-ups with each other
Paul and I have had blow-ups with each
other and I can say through and through
I see you both as partners I see you
both as people I absolutely love and
you're two people that in public I have
almost cried when talking about when
when I talk about the situa I told you
this the other night the people were
coming up to me at the meet and greets
and saying to me like dude taste buds
like brought like me and my girlfriend
together it's like why we're dating and
that wasn't the part that got me the
part that got me was they said like how
long have you and Sal been friends and I
just started talking about well I was
like well during the pandemic is when we
got and I started getting like
yeah no he's a good guy man
I'm like I'm like like just kind of like
you know what I mean like I did the
Honeydew and and sickler
interviewed me about the bar and I was
shout out to Ryan sickler get better
brother get better we're all thinking of
you yeah get better brother the best the
best dude man but he was interviewing me
about the bar and uh and at the end of
it I was talking about like like like
how like the [__] I remember at the time
I that that [__] Jeep I had at the
time yeah was in the sh it was in the
shop again and Paul called me and he
goes he goes
I know you're in Cali he goes listen
um give me the number of the garage I
want to go over there and talk to those
guys because I don't I don't know man
this is I want to make sure they're not
doing anything to [__] with you because
it keeps coming back to the shop and I
told my dad that and my dad goes that's
a one in a million friend and uh and I
started telling the story I'm sick I was
thinking I was trying to cry yeah but my
point is it's like pointed that's
exactly yeah he thought of you and said
I'm going to contribute I'm going to
outwardly do something for you that I
don't have to do it all because I care
you know and and there are there are
plenty of guys that would have had the
the arguments you and I have had off air
about whatever it was that would have
went [__] this yeah you know and funny
enough
it's the same thing you guys are talking
about with your with your ladies it's
like it's the same [__] thing yeah
it's it's it's recognizing all the other
[__] that makes you not go [__] this man
this is a [__] headache yeah you know
what I mean yeah whatever well I don't
know dude look what this person does for
me I want to give back to them you know
like it's beautiful yeah it's [__]
beautiful no matter what happens I love
you baby
Indian food Chinese food go
all right how does it start it just it's
time to oh okay here we go time to beat
there's all the salty is gone yeah yeah
yeah so what is it now I'll throw
another one at you no your head's too
small
[Laughter]
all right versus defending uh Indian
food I'm defending Chinese food versus
you picked Indian food yeah because you
said you've gotten it well I'll let you
pick I'll let you explain so so yeah
what happened I would say over the last
five six years is somebody was like have
you tried Indian because every time you
want to order it's always what the four
go-to's it's Mexican Italian food
Chinese so all those right burger and
and everyone's like dude you don't do
Indy you don't do Indian and everybody
said the same thing oh that curry [__]
oh they're too and I'm like let me go
someone's no it's not always like that
it's not always Curry it's not always
like that so I of course tried these
dishes and I was in Vegas and somebody
goes hey there's a place Off the Strip
called mint and they go they do a lunch
thing it's like 10 bucks and it's
Gourmet Indian so I was like let me try
it's like it's going to blow my go there
and I was like dude my whole [__]
world just changed I was like this is
amazing then I got into the chicken
vindaloo which is really spiced because
I like spice then I got into the lamb
vindaloo then I said to my wife who's
the pickiest eater in the world you know
I mean she's the [__] pickiest and
she goes I can't do Indian party nuts
she did she got a chicken so you're an
Italian guy that's eating a lot of
vindaloo this guy's a vindaloon right
here all right so here's the thing
please don't write to us don't even
comments that's a great it's a great it
was a good it was a good line here's the
[__] Pro there's been a sham in our
country there's been a scam in our
country and it comes from China and it
comes from China
it comes from China just like the covet
scan okay
okay listen to me these [__]
chop up vegetables they put a little
chicken with it and it feels heavy it
feels heavy and they put the sauce and
it's good the chicken's good the beef's
good but it's a lot of [__] that
throw peanuts [__] peanuts [__] your
peanuts okay you come in here right now
how dare you come in here right now
you're saying it's quantity not quality
oh the bed feels heavy because we're
going to give you big [__] pounds of
white rice nobody gives a [__] about how
dare you okay don't finish that rice no
but you put it in the fridge
how dare you come in here right now with
a sauce complaint with Indian food I've
been to your Indian buffet by the way
congrats for being the first human being
that's ever said this I know a good
restaurant off the strip in Vegas
nobody's ever said that the good
restaurants are in the casinos the
reason the ones are off the strip is
because they couldn't get into the
casinos okay so here's the deal all
right I've been to Indian buffets okay
everything it's Vats dude it's vets
there's the one in the orange sauce the
one in the red sauce the one in the
brown sauce there's a lot of rice
involved and then they think that that
bread is carrying the mailman that
you're gonna dip the none the naan is
gonna you're gonna D they're not like
I've never had a pita by the way you
know I mean it's different than Pita
though
they put Garlic on the naan I was making
no I was making a joke I get it I get it
but like
Chinese food has been Americanized you
get [__] hungry right after it you
want to know why because you didn't have
enough [__] protein because I keep
giving vegetables all I get is protein
in Chinese restaurants dude this is my
this is how I go now we're talking
American Chinese
restaurants I've been to China you want
to talk true Chinese food and I'll talk
true Chinese food and true American food
you ever had real Peking duck because
I've had it dude you you can't yeah
nothing on Earth will hold the candle to
it
[Music]
it literally
it literally else in your mouth listen
listen I can't [__] with that argument
because I've never eaten Chinese food in
China I'm talking American then I'll
come at you American Chinese food you're
not getting substance I get spare ribs
boom all meat chewy fatty not great stop
it dude stop chewy fatty acros nothing
beats an egg and that girl's incredible
I'll give you that nothing beats an egg
roll give you an egg roll pork fried
rice okay what yeah pork fried rice what
and then how much are you throwing out
or leftovers General Sal's chicken
you're complaining
plans that I don't even touch dude beef
and broccoli all right sweet and sour
chicken sweet and sour chicken no sauce
no I mean like not in essentially you're
talking about there's the sweet and sour
sauce but I mean you're you're the
dishes you were talking about yeah even
beef and broccoli I wouldn't put in in
that category you're talking about like
when you get like the chicken and
vegetables or whatever and it's got a
lot of the brown sauce on it and yeah
it's like a lot of carrots and celery
and Bs yeah yeah a lot of onions a lot
of chopped onions in there who gets that
see what Chinese they give you a big
bucket of the brown sauce but see the
thing is that's a throw away but when
you order Indian you don't have to
specialize it to get more meat when you
get that thing first of all when you
order Indian you get the big aluminum
tray and when you open it it's Lo when I
got the I got lamb vindaloo the other
day right it was loaded with lamb tender
as hell heavy and just a few potatoes
where the majority of the dish was the
lamb that I'm [__] paying for I'm
gonna take questions of the world and
they come out with this long flat big
round naan with garlic crunchy that you
could dip the red sauce in then I had
Indian wings dude Indian Wings lemony
with the seasoning took it to another
level I'm not saying but I'm not saying
Chinese food's bad but gone to my
[__] head gun to my [__] head if
you tell me that I could only do one
more the rest of my life American now
not China Chinese food but American
Indian versus American
I would go I'd go in here nuts I don't
know enough about Indian food so I get
scared to order it myself because I'm
like I don't want to order stuff and I
get it and I don't like it but when I've
been like when by people I know that
like Indian food order it for like the
like the table or the event I always
like the only thing I don't like is
traditional Curry right and that's what
I but that's not everything no that's
not it but I don't I don't like it
something disagrees with me I think when
people think Indian they think that I
hate Curry and look Ginger's got its
limits man you know Ginger's running all
through the Indian uh menu and after a
while it gets to be too isn't that
ginger in the Chinese menu no Ginger no
Ginger's way more uh like Japanese food
Japanese
yeah they shave the ginger but you know
what I'm saying you got a lot of Ginger
popping in that Indian food and it it
starts to get like come on now but how
what am I wrong but no but what are the
percentage Joe what are the percentage
of people in America that even eat
Indian food because I bet you it's a lot
less than I don't think people I think
people are afraid of it but so far but
so far and out here it's like you're a
man in your 40s how do you eat it you
don't eat it it's available to me it's
not my go-to because it's available to
me I know you know what I mean I mean
being living in New York it's like I can
get it whenever I want it I mean but
like it's I need to I need to explore it
more and find the dishes that I like so
I can put them in my rotation it's on me
why I don't know Chinese because that
goes down the list like you said yeah
and I'm I'm not going to get to Indian
before I go oh I could use it I will try
I could use a pizza I can use oh my God
we'll try okay I will try the vindaloo
okay it sounds like it might be too
spicy for me because I don't like food
makes me sweat I I will say this it does
okay but I will say this this is what I
don't know I just said that because you
just said that okay what but
here's my here's what I'm hearing from
you right now yeah I'm hearing a lot of
smoke yeah a little bit of mirrors okay
and I'll tell you why okay I think you
just Define the entire Indian menu by
one dish that you really like which is
lamb vindaloo no there's everything and
also if you go to a quality and you're
talking you go to a quality Indian
restaurant and you get a quality Indian
lamb vindaloo coming out if you go to a
quality Chinese restaurant these dishes
you speak of of all sauce and lots of
onion bro you know that ain't the case
that's that's take out like Hole in the
Wall Chinese you know what I mean like
the little joints I get it sometimes
that happens there but you go to a
quality Chinatown Chinese restaurant
with the ducks in the window and
everything they're not [__] around
with anything you've been to a quality
in I was in London by the way if you go
to London you got to go because it's the
food there is terrible but Indian the
population so everybody said since you
like it yeah everyone's like since you
got to do it and me and my family did it
but I'll tell you Sal we did go my wife
goes oh my God I'm just in the mood for
Indian tonight my kids my kids are 13
and 10. I want Indian and we feel full
we don't get hungry like the Chinese
food after you get hungry you get kids
you guys went to like a babubat type
Place Seinfeld's the guy what like but
hold on your kids are saying this my
kids are saying this my 13 year old my
13 year old son said the other day I go
guys you want to get sushi or Chinese
and and uh my daughter and son go kind
of in the mood for Indian and Stacy goes
oh yeah I'm gonna move okay you're in
them but but you're dodging my point my
point was not that your kids like Indian
food or not we've established right I
get that yeah my point is this I'm
saying if you get quality Indian food
you're saying you get what you pay for
I'm saying if you get quality Chinese
food you get what you pay for okay but
I've taken out both and and it's it's
not the same yeah not the shame in what
sense not the same and I'm not getting
like when I order chicken vindaloo or
lamb vindaloo or chicken tikka masala
and that comes uh delivered it's like
I'm at the restaurant and it's a lot
whereas if I have to go to a Chinese
food restaurant I think I don't think
that's true I think you're going to the
world can I say one thing and I love
Chinese food but I will say that like
it's it's as big as the [__] menu is
it's kind of like the same in every
place you know and and and I don't know
if this is a pro or a con but like
you can get Chinese food
from 25 different places here and it's
the same thing and [__] yeah no no
but those are those again I'm gonna go
back to this those are the joints those
are something to say for consistency but
also there's no like there's no
variation but hold on I disagree and
this is why I disagree you can't Define
it by the little takeout spots that
would be like saying like you could go
to one of those well hold up but hold on
that's how I can see my point is no and
I like that kind of Chinese film I'm not
knocking it but I'm saying that would be
like saying oh if you go to all the hot
dog places in this neighborhood it's all
kind of the same it's like well yeah
dude their little takeout drink that's
what they do they're probably getting
food from the same suppliers and all
that stuff I'm saying go into Chinatown
go sit down I live on the border of
Chinatown I gotta place a block for my
apartment where the Ducks are hanging in
the window you sit down at that place
you order duck you want to talk quality
for your money well you order duck for
15 you get half a duck and dude I'm
talking it is two pounds of duck you get
ribs it is two pounds of ribs it's crazy
it is so much food yeah it's and it's
and it's amazing but I will tell you
that but maybe this is this is a moot
point because
it's ditto for that for the Indians yeah
but that's why I'm saying you can't say
well when I order interviewed I get this
when I go to Chinese food I get that no
you gotta you gotta go to the equivalent
okay but I've had everything but the
variations what South stands very I've
got General Chow's chicken which has
been incredible because the bread wasn't
that you know but then you could get
General Chow's chicken where it's this
lumpy [__] of course but that doesn't
happen with Indians that's [__]
that's [__] what do you mean I've
been to tons of Indian buffets okay over
the years okay and and I've and I've not
eaten in many of them because a bunch of
people want to go because they go we all
would have gone I always walked in and
out of tons of Indian buffets no no I
mean like I've literally I've literally
gone to an Indian buffet and been like
I'm not gonna eat like but everybody
wants to do this I'll just wait till
later I'm not into it but I tons but my
point is this I've gone to Indian spots
and I have seen the Indian food
equivalent of what you're saying about
Chinese food where I'm like
it's it's a bunch of that's a very soupy
Saucy things there's some curries there
whatever I I would be willing to bet
based on what you're saying if you
brought me to a quality Indian
restaurant and I sat down it would be a
very different experience yes just like
with Chinese food I've had terrible
General Tso's chicken over the years
it's because I didn't get it from a
place that made quality General Sal's
chicken they don't make quality food I
don't think that's a fair comparison I'm
saying if you want to get down to just
flavor versus flavor
I like I'm gonna take Chinese food why
because they got the spicy dishes they
got the sweet dishes they got the egg
rolls fried chicken wings from a Chinese
restaurant to me are bangers spare ribs
from Chinese restaurants or bangers
wonton soup hot and sour soup yes it has
a big variety but I do say that there's
no like spare ribs sucked you you could
talk about this in a rubbery and fatty
they stink you're wrong you're wrong
that's a very very high risk when you
order spare it in my whole life out of
all the times we've ordered spare ribs I
could count on one hand less that that
would be like oh my God this is good
meat dude they're [__] shaving the
fat off of that thing and putting it in
some places are probably okay
no I get on the bone yeah
and I and I like Chinese food probably
more I eat it more and I like it more
and I I think I'm gonna start ordering
Indian because I want to be I want I
want to try this I want to try this
[__] Branford Marsalis that he's
talking about it sounds good it's Winton
marsala I want to try this man this
Vanderpool [__] no no listen listen
I'll take two things I'll say two things
it's kind of weird that you could take a
I don't know if it's weird again I don't
know how to think about this but it's a
point that you could take any places
Chinese food menu and use that as the
menu for any other Chinese food place
it's the same thing with Indian food is
it though yes listen I would say I would
say in some ways yes but but dude the
spices that I'm hitting with the sauce
and the things that they're putting on
not Curry I'm talking about the way it
hits with the flavor oh they're big with
flavor this flavors bold flavors they're
[__] nuts all right all right that's
fair that's fair I think I think some of
this is just preference palette
preference right I I like that Chinese
combines sugary with the spice I like
that or you have the option to do that
my favorite thing in the world from a
Chinese American Chinese restaurant is
and this even the Chinatown like sit
down quality spots have egg rolls
I I love an egg roll I love it with some
of the and by the way you know you can
only get that orange duck sauce in New
York and in Philly on the East Coast you
go out west Duck Sauce is red it's red
oh for sure yeah yeah okay and it tastes
way more like store-bought sweet and
sour sauce and I don't like it but my
favorite thing to do is to take that
duck sauce
and right next to it the hot mustard and
mix it dunk I dunk it I keep it
separated and I dunk it into both
it opens my nostrils up but it's sweet I
love it dude I love it I will say this
is is the menu that in it that you're
ordering from though it is actually uh
authentic Indian food whereas the
Chinese food is well there's not there's
not Indian joints everywhere right like
the way there's Chinese joints but the
menu you're ordering from is authentic
Indian Cuisine yeah there's a restaurant
in our in our neighborhood that delivers
as opposed to like but but I I hear what
your point is yeah and I'm not saying
you're wrong but how do we know that how
do we know that it's not Americanized
Indian food oh because well no well the
dishes we've been to the restaurant that
delivered to us and it was I mean but
I'm saying I've been to Chinese
restaurants where entire staff is
Chinese and tired Decor is Chinese uh or
you know all every any every ornament in
there is or Oriental I don't know if the
land but my point is is my point is is
if I took I've been to Chinese places
where if if we walked inside and I said
Paul we just went to a Warp Zone and
we're actually in China you wouldn't be
able to tell that we weren't but I've
also been to China and had traditional
Chinese food like from there and it is
quite different it is quite different
there's there's there are connected
there's connective tissue but it is
quite different so my point is is how
the hell do we know if there's not an
Americanized we've never been to India
and had Indian food right yeah but right
no I've never but you know it but it is
those dishes are I mean the people that
how do you know I mean because okay I'll
put it this way I've been to London like
a dozen times there's so many Indian
restaurants there yeah because as a
matter of fact I stayed in hotels with
only the whole entire uh room service
menu is India I've been I've been to
Scotland
I've never been to England yeah because
of Scotland I've been to Ireland Ireland
Chinese food in those places was very
similar to American Chinese food in
China is different I I guess I don't
know actually some of the places in New
York Chinatown shave way closer to it
yeah but can't you go to you could go to
an Italian restaurant and go how do we
know this is and you're like oh well
she's from Sicily which by the way it is
different in Italy like the pizza is
different food in Italy is completely
different than Italian food here but
there's one yeah you know you never see
in Italy they're never like we have
chicken parmesan
the one thing the one column and I hear
what you're saying I haven't had it in
in China so I don't know but the one
check mark that indeed except for me
yeah the one check mark that the Indian
gets for me that that simply just does
not exist in the Chinese food American
thing is I have never had a meal with my
family of Indian food and been hungry
later where when I get Chinese food I'm
[__] I'm hungry
no I look I think that that is I know
it's a thing I think it's I think it's
an old wives tale at this point any time
I get and I think the Chinese food has
been very unfairly uh uh stereotyped in
this sense any time I ever get take out
food or food delivered whatever it is
whether it's Chinese food whether it's
faster than Chinese food it comes fast
and hot it's that I love it what does
that tell you no what does that tell you
no it tells you that there's a little
lady up there chopping [__] onions
and peppers and saying throw that
let me finish this
any any count I get at home pizza
Chinese food KFC whatever the [__] it is
if if there's more
I'm hungry a few hours later and I go
back and I eat more of it anything so
you're saying it's a function that they
give you a big quantity no I think it's
a function of that's what take out it
the takeout does that to you no but you
go anytime you could take out there's
nothing better than that second round to
the fridge later it's cold you're like
oh it's kind of like cold burritos
I think the point is too I think I just
had a conversation with myself and then
sat up and said that's the point as I
said that I realized that because I'm
thinking of the authentic dinner like if
you go if me you and Sal went to a good
Italian restaurant right now right right
and we got the fresh mutts and we get
the prosciut to start yeah and we get a
glass of wine and the bread comes out
and then all of a sudden you get a nice
dish whether it's eggplant or [__]
ravioli or lasagna right I'm done dude
I'm not gonna be I'm done if we win
trying to save room for the cappuccino
yeah so cappuccino you got a little
tiramisu you're done I I you feel like
that take out Indian with take out
Indian you feel like you had a gourmet
feel I do not feel like that with
Chinese unless I sit down in the Chinese
food interesting so you're saying on the
whole Indian food feels much more like
real fulfilling your actual food yes
Chinese food yes is take out food hold
on hold on a second hold on you just
said you don't feel like that if you sit
down in the Chinese restaurant no I'm
saying if I sit down in a Chinese
restaurant like you're saying not take
out and they [__] don't overload it
with the rice and everything because I
have a meal it's better
I think it's better years but my point
is this is it's a it's a very unfair
comparison my point with Chinese takeout
and now I'm hungry an hour later Chinese
takeout is in the Indian food is not
classic takeout never was probably never
will be I mean what else could it
compete with Chinese food to take out
well that's my point Pizza
Burgers you know Burgers uh uh but Pete
my my in my head classic takeouts ready
yep Chinese food
bucket of chicken
Pizza whoa wait a minute you mean on
what's on on how much people get or a
bucket of chicken to me is classic
takeout that's why it is that's why is
that in order is that what you meant no
I'm saying like I'm saying like if
you're talking let's see take out number
one though if you had to rank is pizza I
mean that's number one pizza should we
do that should I do pizza versus Chinese
food
probably people in the world we're
trying to figure out
I'm saying there are certain things that
you that are just take out right you see
a bucket of chicken you're like that is
classic takeout food right any one of
those foods that I just mentioned when I
bring them home yep I eat some I'm full
and a few hours later I want to eat more
because there's something about it
mentally that triggers you in a certain
way any one of those Foods if I went and
sat down and ate them like a human being
on a plate and all that stuff I would
not feel that same way I don't know why
that is what it is this thing your mind
is primed to but you know what I really
think it comes down to dude I think it
comes down to not a lot of people and
that's why there's not a lot of Indian
takeout people are afraid of Indian they
don't try it a lot of people don't try
it and that's why you haven't and that's
why when I say it to people they always
go like what well you have to like you
have to get yourself familiar with it
otherwise people open their mind and say
because everybody does the same thoughts
Curry it's Curry it's not what are you
doing after this what I'm dead serious
yeah yeah I would too I've been like I
wanted you know Chinese food yeah I
gotta go I might have to I gotta be up
by my house by 9 30. all right because I
will go get Indian food with you after
this and you you take me through it I'm
dead serious I don't know I gotta find
out if you don't have time you don't
have time yeah yeah no why can't let's
can we do it again and then like [__]
throw yeah but I'm telling you right now
you became Louie dumps you're like I got
that thing I got the thing with the guy
I got a p from Bronxville
I get a piece so bad go to the phones
without me
and this one's coming out late when's
this one coming out so it's coming out
the sick the 13th guys tomorrow yeah
guys oh this is the Valentine's Day
episode wow it worked out guys tomorrow
Valentine's Day I'm gonna be at the
Pittsburgh improv with Pittsburgh's own
Joe bartnick is on the show so we're
gonna be there it's gonna it's one show
only uh tickets are going it might be
sold out if there's a few left scoop
them right now all right so I'm gonna be
uh Zanies in Chicago
um March 2nd through the 4th I'm gonna
be at Providence the 30th through April
1st uh then I'm doing a one-nighter Salt
Lake City uh April no I'm sorry I'm
gonna be a Salt Lake City Wise Guys
April 14th through uh 15th and then I'll
be at the Denver Comedy Works
um on the 16th I got Austin I got Tampa
I got Charlotte and Raleigh just added
so you go to paulversy.com please check
out the um nocturnal admission my
special nocturnal admissions was
globally trending on Netflix is doing
great thank you guys you got two on
there right uh no I have uh no the
Netflix one and then the other one's
gonna be available on YouTube I'll say
this which I did uh Comedy Central in 18
but the one that I just did this summer
is on Netflix now two podcasts I do the
version effect which is now in studio
like a TV show like this and I co-host
anything better so uh with Burr so you
guys could check that out too and uh
yeah check out my dates paulversy.com
thank you for having me I was at both
tapings of your specials you were
[__] loved them you were I loved them
you were at both of the biggest Knights
of my career yeah I'll always be there
oh you're the best and you [__]
killed him well thank you man both of
you so much yes uh so if you don't know
Paul I mean you get you got to get to
know him uh guys real quick uh
impracticaljokerslive.com we are on tour
right this second there's like 40 50
cities we're adding more but I only want
to tell you about the ones coming up the
North Charleston uh uh uh February 16th
Charlotte North Carolina the 17th
Waterloo New York uh the 18th
and then uh Washington DC the 19th and
then another big one another four day
weekend Niagara Falls Ontario on March
9th the Prudential Center here in Newark
New Jersey so psyched about that on
March 10th uh Wallingford Connecticut on
March 11th and then Long Island UBS
arena in Belmont Park on March 12th I am
so excited to go to that Arena I was a
lifelong Islanders fan that's a that's
an I haven't been to the new Arena yet
we're supposed to help open up that
Arena and the tour got canceled during
coven so super excited about uh the
Prudential Center and about the UBS
Arena and practicaljokerslive.com and
also if any men or women want to compete
for derose's love
please write in the comments yes reach
out to us we are going to cast this
thing I would love to do that we should
throw some guys in I don't know I have
plenty of time let's do it yeah
10 is airing right now it started
February nights on Thursdays at 10
o'clock it's now on both True TV and TBS
at the exact same time simulcast so you
can watch on either Network and uh yeah
it was a great season super super fun a
lot of crazy guests uh check that out
Joe I guess is taking a [__] uh Joe not
a lot of crazy comments on this one no
it seems pretty one-sided yeah right
most of the comments just feel like uh
Indian food white people shouldn't be
talking about Indian food that kind of
whole thing what would Trump
says this is like very random I don't
even know what that means um Indian food
is what killed Gandhi so many friends
it's just all trolling on this one yeah
okay nothing too constructive to be
honest no that's bad it's disappointing
uh what was I gonna say uh about you oh
Joe DeRosa info.com yes for all Joey's
dates he's got a lot up right now and
then also go down to Joey roses in the
Lower East Side of New York on Rivington
Street they're open seven days a week
check out that the sandwiches are
unbelievable Space is really cool it's a
great neighborhood little spot check
that out I guess Joe is doing a number
two
there was 18 000 votes on this one this
might be our biggest poll in a while
yeah in a while yeah you guys ready you
ready yeah sorry all right all right
let's go to the phones
no we call it going to the phones it's
really going to the comments
yeah
two percent is Indian food okay well
look I had a feeling you're going up
against them okay well listen dude I'm
going up against you that's like going
up against it's literally probably
number two to Pizza when it comes to
takeout yeah yeah I needed a win too
that's good
you're counting that as a win
[Laughter]
what the [__] instead we said name food
you love you said Indian food I was like
all right you know if if those 22 people
22 percent of people tell somebody you
know I'll start a movement dude a little
bit slowly but surely man like the first
you want to come on I'll drink Pizza you
take Aboriginal food it'll be great
um uh yeah I thought you made good
points I I thought Chinese food is the
king you got a kid to throw in the king
there but I thought you did make good
points and I'll tell you why I'm coming
away from this genuinely excited to go
and try a bunch of Indian for me too
dude I I'm not gonna lie the last time I
bought because I would always do at
first when I first got into it I would
always start with chicken do the chicken
vindaloo and they're like listen it's
really hot you're gonna be sweating but
then when I was in um London I was like
hey do you have vindaloo and he goes
yeah we don't have chicken we have the
lamb though and then I realized like
that was I think that's like the like
the real more like authentic dude the
chunks of lamb were this big and you're
like is it going to be dry dude and it
just like melted with the seasoning and
the Heat and I was like this is another
and then I dipped the garlic naan and by
the way the one thing about Indian food
is when you get the non-delivered take
out it's nothing like it's it's not as
crispy as when they cook it out of the
oven and give it to you but when you dip
it in that sauce and you get it it's
almost like the the white rice version
of Chinese it's really really good so I
would just tell anybody any listeners
like if you're thinking about it you
don't know you know try the right dish
if you get the right dish you'll have
another option at night there you go all
right that's it I still love you buddy
oh dude I always love you there you go
nice there you go all right taste buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two Fool's gonna fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they're coming to the mic